hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hack now this indeed game
on gamejolt hi you think that I need
training excuse me do you know who I am
[Music]
my vision sin are you talking about my
eyeballs why should I do that
why thought I thought that being the
vulnerable was bro portal companion you
[ __ ] oh I can lift a loo with the
right button
okay okay so I can't hack through that
one bucket hook a karate chop that bad
boy in dubrow town I'll get here well I
did it hey look at me look at me
Oh looky looky at me can i I team to be
at the end of them Oh got a karate chop
this BAM baby oh you beat this level
could be better though I've got so many
points if that was dollars I'd be so
happy three acts okay well I'll go to
the next level in I have no idea what's
happening but I feel pretty confident in
my abilities to hack stove well hi hello
I can't can't walk through that get a
hack it
pachow with my magic fingers around my
green circle around my eyeball boobie
monkey whoa whoa I don't know how I love
it I love it I already love it oh that's
nice get there I don't know if I want to
do that yet I got to find out what's
going on here in this portal world it's
a mystery
it can't be solved BAM all right hippity
hop oh that's cool
hacker - Jackie hey you come back down I
wasn't ready for that
can you come back now I got a hack it
again this all right fine dooby doo doo
buddy turn that off a TIA wobba t get
crush oh I'm fine
I guess everything turned out better
than expected alright swoop D whoop
teeth swiggity witty alright at least it
remembers where I was looking before
that's awfully handy dandy Randy of that
I don't know what I'm doing with that
but it's amazing
whatever my green laser finger gun is I
want one in real life
thank you it is like portal hey it could
be better though that's what I tell
myself every morning I always could be
better you know I'm never quite as good
as I want to be
oh hello do I have to walk hey how's it
going there
jump oh there's an orange oh there's an
orange okay well I gotta find something
right hey come back here oh oh it's an
invisible rope hey come back here don't
make me sass you cuz I will oh yeah
ah you never mind I couldn't come oh oh
no you goofed me Oh Frick now I got
infinitely more time to come up with an
insult for you
you perp alright we'll let bygones be
bygones just oh ho you went a whoopty on
that one I'll find out okay I got I got
I know it I got a but do come here for
you pick you up
no don't goof me ah I could have jumped
from the other platform well you piece
of [ __ ] now you're really done dead it
because now oh I'm not gonna let up on
the insults whoa this is real I don't
like that I don't like that at all
all right don't go me don't go me I
can't look down I can't look down right
now oh I'm on it okay this is real
apparently it's real I mean I thought it
was real the simulation before was what
looked like not real can you just settle
on the button you piece of Derby yeah
freaking dick oh but I know how to do
this don't give me no yes okay almost
goof myself there II ah do ski alright
you plop on that bad boy right there and
we're going we're golden
so if this is if this is real then
what's the point of it right they're
saying something about in the beginning
of that it was some computer program
telling me that I was doing security on
something and things are vulnerable but
it's not the real world so sebou ski
[Music]
well that's we're gonna go on an
adventure aren't we all right Wow
we're going places good thing they blue
buddy blue buddy Oh what does that do
what does that do ah oh
frickin dick oh I'm Way off
Oh duh Oh dog just dog I just got a
freaking go back and then go through
well I'm done that did me that didn't be
longer than the editing would suggest it
took me haha but we're gonna offers and
like a super smart whoa this camera is
Wibbly oh no why oh why is this the wave
ah Oh teddy sprinkles I was here but I
can't hack any whoa oh oh oh I did not
know that okay well I should go back up
a little bit these puzzles are a thing
hey-ho hey-ho
come here hey ho get over here sorry
that's very rude of me but get on that
button ah we did it
if he's in the real world that I'm a
monkey's uncle I did terribly on that
one I did god-awful but let's keep going
because I don't want to end on that note
whoa does that mean risk of catastrophic
failure or is that a cannon that's gonna
blow up that other cannon I have no idea
whose hit the turret battle looks like
it might be a turret battle who backs
gonna eat you got ya I broke the system
I don't know if I actually broke the
system or Oh a scale we stopped just get
on there and let me jump on you whoa
didn't expect that to actually work hey
broke the system love it oh [ __ ] alright
whatever fine will be like this I know
what it wanted that was a mistake
okay you're gonna move
ah oh they're not powered right now
interest Oh what the Fricke dick well
alright why are you so bad
alright whatever just gonna get out of
here see ya so yeah now I'm gonna get up
on this again
get up on this now I'm gonna go over
here cuz I'm cheating oh hey that looks
like it'll kill me let's test that
theory oh oh it's not if you dodge it No
Oh Frick titty sprinkles all right fine
you want to be that way you're gonna be
that way alright so I'm gonna put you
right there and I'm not gonna ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba why is this no working well
this is that's unfortunate
alright fine then cool what you can take
my prize and be on my way excuse me
alright so there's got to be a way to
start up the power right ow
immediately ow wow you [ __ ]
[ __ ] douche come back come back oh
you're not coming back are you
you're not coming back well I guess I'll
dive in how I died Frick my donker one
like that alright we're moving gonna
snag y'all a snack good snag real good
okay alright so I got you how are you
are you not explody
I'm trying to this should work right ah
Oh gotta aim for the base Oh all your
base are belong to boom welp you're dead
now I grab this and I'll just be on my
way scuse me I don't bubble knock me I
said don't
bubble knock me this is a tight squeeze
all right you know what I don't like
that and you don't like me and we don't
like each other and where did I go okay
whatever you know what we're gonna go
with that is the thing that
happening Oh shitty dicks no no no oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you in a million ways in a
million days [ __ ] you since I think it's
gonna be fine I'm gonna leave this there
now and then drop off well apparently
I'm not apparently I'm gonna go
upside-down err okay if I just time this
welp didn't time that no get back in
your spot yeah it worked I was about to
complain but then it worked okay yes
okay so anyway that is all the time I
got for this one this is cool though I
like it it's pretty darn cool they got
some good mechanics going on here and I
can really appreciate that there's also
some competitiveness to it because
there's speedruns so if you want to play
this game for yourself it's a unique
puzzle and it's got some cool elements
to it I'll put a link in the description
below thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]